santes affiche pour célébrer le
centenaire de la grande guerre des
illustrations originales qui visait
essentiellement à encourager la
population à soutenir l'effort de guerre
l'appui la publicité pour essayer de
justement de faire passer des messages
et la plupart de ces affiches sont les
commandes publiques pour donner son
argent les emprunts dire que tout va
bien
il affiche manger manger des pommes de
terre damnée votre or voilà des slogans
pour effectivement faire en sorte que
cette dans cette guerre soit à l'arrière
irons-nous un peu moins destructrice une
plongée dans la grande histoire qui fait
écho à celle de toutes les familles
françaises
l'occasion pour cette grand mère de
transmettre à son petit-fils
l'importance du devoir de mémoire
moi personnellement j'ai le frère mon
grand père a été blessé
frère de mon grand père est resté à
verdun donc pour moi c'est important
parce qu'il faut pas oublier ceux qui se
sont sacrifiés puis faut pas ça
recommence et puis ils sont tous partis
la fleur au fusil et ça a été vraiment
un énorme carnet je trouve qu'il est
marrant pareil pourquoi tout le monde
sache que les gens c'est pour nous parmi
ces combattants qui ont donné leur vie
pour la france tout ce qui venait des
anciennes colonies
ceux du pacifique seront
particulièrement mises à l'honneur car
le collectionneur natif d'avalon habite
désormais en nouvelle calédonie avallon
point de départ d'un périple
international
l'expédition partira ensuite en
australie au vanuatu et enfin à
l'automne 2015 à numéros